hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an Indian Comedy drama film
called entertainment spoilers ahead
watch out ants take care
the protagonist of the movie is a poor
man named Akil lakhand who is regarded
as a failure by his family and France he
works tirelessly in the advertisement
industry for a meager salary to pay for
his ailing father's medical bills while
jumping from one assignment to another
he also makes time for his longtime
girlfriend sakshi one day Akil proposes
marriage to her at a park sakshi happily
says yes but she also puts forth the
condition that her strict father should
agree to it this slightly upsets that
kill but nonetheless he decides to pay
him a visit sakshi's father Mahesh is a
money-obsessed man who goes to extremes
to save every penny he can that rhymed
when Akil asks sakshi's hand in marriage
the greedy man flat out refuses he
asserts that he won't let his daughter
marry a poor man like a keel as long as
he is alive dejected Akil visits his
best friend jugnu for some respite they
chat for a while which eventually makes
him feel better jugnu even offers to
accompany a appeal to his father's
hospital however when the two friends
reached there they encounter a keel's
old man Raju acting and dancing around
with a nurse they also overhear him
admitting that he was just pretending to
be sick so that he could enjoy the
five-star hotel-like service in the
hospital if that nurse doesn't tell her
boss about this they need to fire her
ass taken aback Akil confronts his
father and calls him lying scum he has
started to wonder if the man is his real
father after all surprisingly his doubts
are proven right as Raju admits that
they are not related by blood akil's
biological father abandoned him and his
mother at a young age one day Raju met
them in a train which later met with an
accident he and Akil survived the crash
but the mother perished later when the
Indian government announced a large
compensation to the families of the
deceased ones Raju adopted Akil his only
motive was to claim the compensation
hearing all this Akil is stunned and
infuriated so he beats up the man before
returning home in the next scene Ezekiel
lamented about his pathetic life to
jugnu he notices a chest in his house
that he had never noticed before inside
he finds Love Letters from his real
father to his mother and also a locket
with their pictures on it in a shocking
turn of events it is revealed that
akil's real father is Panola jori an
Indian billionaire based in Bangkok he
recently passed away and is Left Behind
a massive Fortune of 30 billion with no
apparent air Akil is sad about his
biological father passing away but he is
also elated that he will inherit the 30
billion property he feels that God has
finally done him Justice after
celebrating with jugnu Akil flies to
Bangkok to attend his father's wake
there he meets Mr Joe Reed's lawyer
Sheikh Akil wastes no time in
introducing himself as Mr Joe Reed's
long-lost son lying claim to the fortune
left behind by the billionaire he offers
to provide proof but Sheikh believes him
this is because Akil looks awfully
similar to his late mother she could met
her quite a few times before she
perished in the train accident your nose
looks familiar here's 30 billion dollars
once the introductions are out of the
way Sheik delivers some damning news he
explains that Akil is not the heir to
the Joey Empire because the late
billionaire transferred all of his
property to someone else before he died
it is then revealed that the certain
someone is Mr Joey's loyal dog
entertainment with a name like that that
dog probably knew how to lick peanut
butter if you know what I'm saying Akil
is shocked and he refuses to accept that
his father would give all his property
to a dog in response Sheik Comforts him
and reveals that after akil's mother
died Mr Joey regretted abandoning his
son and tried searching for him however
when Akil was not found he went into
depression one day he tried to commit
the unthinkable but the dog
entertainment saved him from that day
onwards the two became really close Chic
also asks Akil to not address
entertainment as a dog he explains that
Mr Joe Reed never treated entertainment
like an animal and always thought of him
as his son distraught Akil starts
cursing at his fate he believes that no
matter what God gives him he will
somehow manage to mess it up soon jugnu
also flies to Bangkok in hopes of living
a lavish life with Akil however when his
best friend tells him about the dog he
is stunned Akil decides to give up and
Ponders about returning back to India
but jugnu stops him explaining that if
he returns to India empty-handed he will
never be able to marry sakshi instead he
advises Akil to kill the dog and take
back what belongs to him the latter is
hesitant at first but for the sake of
his future he agrees following this Akil
approaches Sheik and requests that he be
made the dog's caretaker he says that it
is the least he deserves to his luck
Sheik agrees but instead of being
appointed as the caretaker Akil has made
entertainment's personal made
nonetheless he and jugnu start hatching
a plan to take out the animal they will
seek help from a book called 500 Ways to
Kill by accident first they try to
electrocute entertainment using the
kitchen fridge however the dog tanks
their plan and electrocutes them instead
the next day the two friends lure
entertainment into the jungle using a
female dog hoping to feed him to wild
animals however entertainment tricks
them and safely returns home while Akil
ends up falling down from a height and
injuring himself in another attempt the
two friends try to feed entertainment
with poison but once again the
intelligent golden retriever outsmarts
them during their several failed
attempts jugnu and Ikea learn about two
brothers Quran and Arjun who are Mr Joe
Reed's second cousins the scene then
cuts to the Central Prison where Quran
and Arjun are currently held for
conspiring I mean sorry conspiring to
kill Mr Joe Reed it turns out they
wanted to take over his property however
Every Time Entertainment stopped them
and saved his master although the
brothers have almost completed their
sentences and are going to be set free
in two days they hatch an early escape
plan so that they can celebrate arjun's
birthday outside these guys are idiots
the Step Brothers successfully execute
their plan and managed to get out
however in the last stage they are not
able to board their getaway train
because of the goofy Young Brother
arjun's stake they are eventually caught
and brought back to their cell
frustrated the two get into an argument
and Quran almost raises his hand on his
little brother this makes arjune
emotional and he wonders if Quran cares
about him at all the latter also gets
emotional and he assures arjune that he
loves him unconditionally despite the
fact that they are Step Brothers the two
then reconcile and celebrate our June's
birthday inside their jail cell the
celebrations turn even better when they
learn that Mr Jory has passed away
recently meanwhile sakshi and her greedy
father mahash also fly to Bangkok after
learning about akil's billionaire father
they head straight to his place and meet
Chic Mahesh is astounded by the richness
inside the mansion and he immediately
offers his daughter to the heir of the
Joey Empire Sheik is expectedly puzzled
and he opposes the proposal that sakshi
manages to convince him by explaining
about their long history soon Akil
arrives with entertainment and it
finally Dawns on Mahesh that the dog has
actually inherited all of Mr Joey's
estate infuriated he proceeds to leave
with his daughter Akil pleads for a
chance but Mahesh berates him for losing
to a dog meanwhile Quran and Arjuna also
arrive and watch the encounter from a
distance they are devastated to learn
about akil's entry into the picture and
decide to focus on getting rid of him
because they figure that the dog will
die in a couple of years anyway
meanwhile Akil and jugnu hatch another
plan to take out entertainment this time
they plan to kill the dog in Snow White
Arena a frozen lake in the hilly region
of Thailand the following day Akil
brings entertainment to the lake and
sends him to fetch a ball over the
dangerously thin ice after entertainment
obliges Akil strikes the ice and a large
crack starts following the dog at the
same time Quran and Arjuna appear behind
a kill and hit the ground sending
another crack after him lo and behold
entertainment suddenly takes a U-turn
and runs toward a kill much to his
astonishment the smart golden retriever
then jumps at a Keel and pushes him away
from the approaching danger
unfortunately in the process
entertainment falls into the freezing
Lake instead Akil instantly regrets his
actions as he realizes that
entertainment sacrificed his life to
save him he frantically starts looking
for the dog by punching the ice with his
bare hands sadly the dog is nowhere to
be found devastated Akil breaks down in
tears and starts cursing himself but
right then entertainment pops out of the
water this finally allows that Keel to
breathe a sigh of relief later he
apologizes to the portrait of his late
father and leaves the Mansion for good
in the next scene Quran and Arjun arrive
at the mansion with their lawyers and
confront Sheik they claim that the Joey
Empire actually belongs to the
entertainment a private limited company
that was started by Mr Joey in
partnership with Quran and Arjun some
years ago now that the old man has died
the brothers are the sole owners of the
company Chic rejects the suggestion
arguing that Mr Joe Reeves will mentions
his dog entertainment and not the
company however Quran and Arjun retort
that Mr Joe Reed doesn't mention the
word in the will unfortunately the case
is dragged to court and the judge rules
in favor of the brothers after their
Victory Quran and Arjun immediately
kicked the dog out of the Mansion the
incident devastates Chic and he almost
loses hope but Akil and jugnu returned
back after learning about the Court
ruling at the airport Akil vows that
he'll get the property back for
entertainment his strategy is to divide
the two brothers and Conquer to do this
Akil first wins their trust by saving
them from the attack of entertainment
and his dog France he then uses this
opportunity to get himself a job of a
servant at the Mansion one day Akil gets
a call from sakshi who informs him that
her father is trying to get her married
to an NRI alarmed Akil immediately
arranges some fake documents and with
the help of those he convinces Mahesh
that he has finally inherited Mr Joe's
estate once that is out of the way Akil
hatches a plan to split the two brothers
by making both of them fall for sakshi
the plan works and the brothers end up
fighting for her however soon they sort
out their differences and decide to let
sakshi go after the first failed attempt
Akil decides to exploit Quran and
arjun's other weakness fear of ghosts
one evening Sheik shows up at the
Mansion to warn the brothers that
entertainment passed away because of
starvation and his ghost will come to
haunt them Akil then tells them stories
of a haunted animal which further
strikes fear into the brother's hearts
that night entertainment pretends to be
a ghost and scares the life out of them
the following day Akil meets Quran and
reveals that there is no ghost his
brother was the one who orchestrated
everything so that he could scare Quran
away and have the property all by
himself after this Akil heads to Arjun
and tells him the same thing later the
brothers confront each other and jugnu
secretly records the entire conversation
on a CD as the brothers argue they
inadvertently admit that they bribed the
judge to win the property case however
after securing the admission jugnu
accidentally drops the CD and the
brothers realize that someone's been
recording their conversation fortunately
before they can destroy the evidence
entertainment swiftly retrieves the CD
then Akil and the others also come out
Furious the brothers threatened to deal
with them and send their goons after
entertainment along Chase follows and
the dog is chased throughout the city
when the goons close in on him Akil
intervenes and takes them on
single-handedly he manages to defeat
them but Quran and Arjun follow the dog
to a stadium there they are about to
strike the poor animal but Akil once
again arrives and stops them a lengthy
battle follows in the midst of it Quran
shoots at a keel but entertainment takes
the Bullet by jumping in front of him
this infuriates a Keel and he angrily
beats Quran in arjune to a pulp he then
proceeds to shoot the brothers but
eventually lets them go when sakshi
reveals that entertainment is still
breathing and that he needs immediate
medical help hearing this Akil
frantically carries the dog and runs
through the busy streets of Bangkok
until he arrives at a hospital there the
doctors remove the bullets but
entertainment's heart doesn't show any
signs of response devastated Akil starts
crying and he even punches the dog
angrily accusing him of being disloyal
lo and behold the punch activates
entertainment's heart and he comes back
to life much to akil's Joy after the dog
completely heals he is brought back to
the Joey Mansion there makesh arrives
and gives his approval to Akil for the
marriage saying that sakshi would be
lucky to have a good-hearted man like a
keel as her husband at the same time
Quran and Arjun also come to apologize
and entertainment decides to forgive
them he looks them in the eye and says
in the final scene Akil and sakshi get
married while busting out some dance
moves to a classic Bollywood song
Entertainment also hooks up with a
female dog and the entire cast joins
them on a group dance the movie ends
with the two couples living happily ever
after subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching